we're losing our capacity to engage with
books we're losing our ability to fall
into other lives and less able to
identify and relate to the people around
us there's that George R.R Martin quote
our reader lives A Thousand Lives before
he dies the man who never reads lives
only one it's a huge problem we gotta
start with moving the cell phones out of
the bedroom we have to start with that I
say listen everybody stop if you drank
up all the wine before bed every night
and drank a bottle of wine when you woke
up every morning we'd have no problem
calling an alcoholic we are phonaholics
now and when everyone has an addiction
it looks like no one has this addiction
read two pages of fiction before bed
when you read the book you have to use
more of your brain and it feels good to
use it this is going to make for a
really good reel on Instagram the case
for reading books